[Music]
so for over 70 years the US ambassador
to the United Nations well they've been
the face of American diplomacy but under
the Obama administration Samantha power
appears to have taken on a much
different much more sinister role
according to brand-new Fox News reports
Samantha Power's had made hundreds of
requests to unmask the identities of
Americans whose conversations were
captured by the Federal foreign
intelligence reporting get this
exceeding two hundred and sixty requests
just in the election year of 2016 alone
sources are now telling Fox News that
Samantha power also quote even sought
information in the days leading up to
president Trump's inauguration according
to this report the sheer volume of
unmasking requests from the former UN
Ambassador is unprecedented now sadly
with Samantha power making these
requests nearly every single working day
in 2016 we must ask the question was she
weaponizing the tools of intelligence
and using the Intel community to spy on
an opposition party during the 2016
presidential election and that's not the
only shocking report we have tonight
just this week we did learn the Trump
campaign chairman Paul metaphor he was
wiretapped by federal investigators
through a secret FISA Court order before
and after the 2016 presidential election
including get this possible
communications with the president were
picked up now earlier this week the Wall
Street Journal they published an article
was entitled did Obama know about commis
surveillance now the piece openly
speculates that high-ranking officials
inside the Obama White House and
President Obama himself may have been
briefed on the FISA surveillance now
unbelievably in March of this year
former Obama Director of National
Intelligence James clapper he said there
was no FISA warrant you may remember
this for the part of the national
security apparatus that I oversaw as DNI
there was no such wiretap activity
mounted against the president the
president-elect at the
as a candidate or against its campaign
there is no fight a court order not not
to my knowledge of anything at Trump
Tower no hang on
then this guy was anyone suspected a
line of Congress also remember this Paul
Manafort was wiretap at Trump Tower
according to these reports but guess
what clapper is now singing a very
different tune admitting that
communications from Trump himself
alright then a candidate and then of
course the president-elect may have been
captured by this surveillance watch what
he said last night is it possible the
president was picked up in a
conversation with Paul Manafort
it's it's certainly conceivable yeah now
we'll have more on this later tonight
Jay Sekulow and cheryl atkinson remember
she was spied on also but first here the
american people have been lied to you've
been lied to repeatedly and nobody on
the left no one in the mainstream media
seems to care now let's talk about the
Russia collusion investigation for a
minute now it's become very evident that
Muller and his team are hell-bent in my
opinion they want to indict Paul
Manafort
and possibly even we're tired Lieutenant
General Michael Flynn Muller is on a
witch-hunt
and by the way the media is helping him
every day build this into a feeding
frenzy this week the Washington Post you
know they have so many false reports
they reported on an email exchange
between manna Ford and a Russian
billionaire where manna Ford actually
offered to give the businessman
briefings related to the campaign the
2016 campaign now a mana Ford spokesman
called the email exchange innocuous and
when you read the words of the letter of
the actual exchange he's right manna
Ford has been very open about his past
international business dealings so it
wouldn't be a shocking revelation that
he would have routine contact with a
businessman how's things going in the
campaign Wow it could have been as
innocent at that do we believe that
you're innocent until proven guilty in
this country you wouldn't know it by
watching the mainstream media then the
report even goes on to admit that
there's zero evidence that these
briefings even ever took place that's
what they're reporting so what you have
here
my opinion is contact it's not collusion
and until evidence is provided you have
to assume that it was just contact then
you have retired Lieutenant General
Michael Flynn now he has served this
country with honor and distinction in
the US Army for over three decades does
he deserve the presumption of innocence
now he has been subjected to unmasking
he has even had his private phone
conversations with a Russian diplomat
well that was leaked to the press and
that is a felony that is a crime that is
a violation of the Espionage Act in fact
it's the only crime we know for sure
that was committed in the eleven months
about talking about this and as I've
said multiple times on this program if
there is actual proved hard evidence of
collusion please show us we will report
it right here in this program here's
another interesting fact we learned this
week Fox News also reporting that
Mulder's team interviewed the Deputy
Attorney General Rod Rosenstein who
happens to be the guy that appointed
Robert Muller he's his boss about what
the Russia investigation can anybody say
conflict of interest and remember Comey
leaked to the New York Times for the
purpose of his friend Muller to become
the special counsel here is why all of
this matters it has now become evident
now more than ever that in America we
have a two-tier justice system in this
country you the American people you are
being fed garbage lies half-truths on a
daily basis you are being betrayed by
these institutions that are supposed to
protect you and be honorable and in the
case of the Justice Department carry out
the rule of law you should be discussed
that I am there are real crimes with
real evidence of real collusion that is
being ignored by the media Robert Muller
and even at this point the Attorney
General Jeff Sessions for example an
investigation needs to be open into this
unmasking and leaking intelligence
scandal why was Samantha Power's the UN
representative unmasking all the names
of these people leading up to the
election nearly one a day well was it
politically motivated seems to me like
it's a very good posture
ability was she weaponizing intelligence
in an election year to go after an
opposition candidate and then you have
former Obama National Security Advisor
Susan Rice and according to other
reports she also was responsible for
rampant unmasking requests in 2016
including the identities of multiple
Trump officials senior officials and
then you got Ben Rhodes close former
aide to President Obama and according to
more reports the House Intelligence
Committee is looking into his requests
for unmasking Americans and of course
you want real crimes look at the
Clintons Hillary actually committed
felonies real crimes and was directly
involved in serious scandals where are
these investigations like when she and
her aides
Oh they destroyed State Department
emails that would be a crime they were
subpoenaed at the time then acid washed
and bleached bit the servers and then
cell phones smashed with hammers that
sounds like obstruction don't forget she
signed off you want to rush a collusion
story on a deal that gave up to 20% of
America's uranium to a Russian company
that donated up to a hundred and forty
five million dollars of the Clinton
Foundation the people involved in that
deal anyone hear the word bribery pay to
play and who can forget the time Bill
Clinton secretly meets with the Attorney
General at the time Loretta Lynch on an
airport tarmac only days before the
FBI's conclusion of its investigation
into Hillary Clinton's server why isn't
that being investigated where is the
outrage in the media in this country
what about the investigation into the
DNC server hack and why didn't the DNC
why wouldn't they hand over their
computers
that got hacked to the FBI and one the
FBI let them get away with it
and according to commis testimony the
bureau was only given access to forensic
forms because the DNC would rather hire
other people and speaking of DNC emails
if you're so concerned about Russia
collusion and you want the truth why
haven't you reached out to Julian
Assange of WikiLeaks
he knows where it came from and he says
it wasn't Russia and he told me back in
January it was not a state party as the
source and the email hack
and not speaking to julian assange and
speaking of muller what about his
conflicts of interest eight of the
sixteen members of Muller's team make
political donations to Obama Clinton and
Democrats and that's only the start of
it
Muller call me best friends and his Fox
News legal analyst Gregg Jarrett
continues to point out that relationship
could be a violation of two laws and you
have Comey he may have broken the law
drafting memos on government computers
removing those documents from the FBI
called me admitted under not under oath
that he is his friend leaked the
contents of the memos to the New York
Times in the hopes that a special
counsel would be appointed and it was
and we can't forget about call me
testifying that Loretta Lynch pressured
him to call the investigation a matter
and he took the talking points as his
own where's the investigation into
possible Ukrainian election interference
Politico reports back in January
Ukrainian efforts to sabotage Trump
backfire Kiev officials scrambling to
make amends with president-elect after
quietly working to boost Clinton Wow
there also needs to be investigations
into the disturbing amount of deep state
leaks Senate report almost a leak a day
in the beginning of the Trump presidency
that's insanity and it's illegal so it's
becoming a clear and present danger not
only to the president but the people
around him but to the country to the
Constitution to the rights our Fourth
Amendment rights to privacy really
where's the DOJ when are they gonna
crack down on these leaks anybody care
about debbie Wasserman Schultz or former
IT staffer and that scandal where's the
special counsel there why did the former
DNC chair keep him on the payroll he had
double billed with everything else we
just laid out here this is the danger it
is clearly in America today a two-tiered
justice system and that's sad that's
real that's scary how can we believe in
equal justice under the law this is now
becoming beyond a constitutional crisis
in my opinion